Ciao a tutti ragazzi, prima di criticare
quello che sto per dire arrivate a fine di questo video
perché troppe persone
ho visto che mi hanno criticato senza
manco aver visto il video in questione.
Scusate se sono un pochino infervorato
ma veramente ci sono stato così male che
finalmente adesso sto trovando le parole
e soprattutto sono riuscito a chiudere un
cerchio che mi sta permettendo
finalmente di fare questo video, perché
altrimenti prima sarebbe stato stupido
sarebbe stato basato sul nulla. Io curo una rubrica qui su Youtube che si chiama Vita Buttata
Esce ogni giovedì.
All'interno di questa rubrica, della scorsa rubrica
ho ricevuto il messaggio
di una ragazza, una ragazza che parlava di
un ragazzo col quale si stava frequentando che ad un certo punto ha cercato di
diciamo, mentre lei dormiva...entrare diciamo dalla porta di servizio. Ok?
Lei non voleva e poi l'ha lasciato fare
ma poi hanno finito diciamo facendolo
entrare dalla porta principale
Ora io e l'ospite inizialmente abbiamo
riso perché il modo in cui ne parlava
era molto leggero. Abbiamo avuto un
momento nel quale abbiamo detto
"Però questo atteggiamento non è corretto nei
confronti della ragazza"
Insomma ci siamo trovati per un momento in una zona grigia
perché dare la tua testimonianza di una
roba di violenza in una rubrica leggera
e anche da come ne parlava la ragazza
abbiamo optato per cercare un pochino
di alleggerire il tema senza però toglierlo del tutto
Sotto mi è stato detto "Questo è uno stupro, non si ride
il fatto che la ragazza non si sia resa conto che era uno stupro non vuol dire che non sia uno stupro
e pian piano questo tipo di  critiche mi ha messo in discussione, mi  ha fatto dire "Cacchio!"
Non è che ho trattato con leggerezza qualcosa di grave e non me ne sono reso conto?
E quindi che cosa ho fatto, ho subito tolto il video e ho rimontato il video
perché avevo anche una seconda
parte in modo da avere un contenuto
divertente ma soprattutto un contenuto
che non mandasse il messaggio sbagliato
Ora sotto a questo video, l'ultimo video, ho ricevuto commenti di persone che dicevano
"Tu non puoi pensare che cancellando così
un messaggio, tu automaticamente ti lavi la coscienza"
Assolutamente no! Assolutamente no! ma questo commento è un commento  cretino
Scusatemi ragazzi se lo dico
E' un commento stupido
Perché io nel momento in cui mi metto in discussione, mi rendo conto dai commenti
che effettivamente sta passando un messaggio
sbagliato e la maggior parte dei commenti sono
"Ma fatevi una vita, ma dai
ma che c***o dite. Ma fregatevene
Quindi io comunque ho la maggioranza dalla mia parte che mi dice "Ma f*******e", di base
Io ho ricevuto un sacco di
commenti di base che erano "F*******e"
ma io per quella minoranza di commenti che dicevano "No questa qui è una cosa seria"
io ho deciso di togliere il video perché?
Perché non volevo che altri commenti di persone
che affrontavano magari quel
video con la stessa leggerezza
pensassero che fosse una cosa normale
E' per quello che ho tolto un video
Perché non tutti avrebbero reagito pensando "Ah questa qui è una cosa sbagliata"
Molte persone avrebbero detto "Ridiamoci
anche noi sopra"
e io ho preferito prima ancora di sincerarmi di qualsiasi cosa di toglierlo
perché mi metto in discussione e io vi giuro invidio le persone, le invidio queste persone
che smettono di seguirmi o...o mi
mettono degli insulti sotto il canale perché?
Perché ho sbagliato e non si può
sempre chiedere scusa quando si sbaglia
Ma voi cosa fate quando fa una c*****a?
Ma soprattutto le persone che non sbagliano mai
che conoscete voi in che modo vi
nascondono le loro c*****e?
Perché i "perfetti" non  esistono...e mi sembra assurdo che debba venirvelo a dire io
Fatto sta non ci ho dormito veramente perché comunque sotto sotto io continuavo a pensare
non tanto a me ragazzi perché a me non me ne frega niente. Se io faccio una c*****a è giusto che paghi
Il mio unico pensiero era "Ma questa ragazza come sta?
Ma a questa ragazza che cosa è successo?
L'avrei fatto prima verso questo...questo video
ma io ho mandato un messaggio a questa ragazza
e ho aspettato che mi rispondesse,
per capire che cosa stava succedendo
Ho sbagliato io? Ho trattato con leggerezza io questo argomento oppure
questo argomento era veramente grave?
e non era assolutamente leggero?
Finalmente mi  ha risposto. Ho parlato un con lei
e adesso le ho chiesto pure il permesso di poter leggere diciamo la nostra conversazione
Dopo fatevi le vostre opinioni ragazzi, perché sono sacrosante. Purtroppo accendo la videocamera e parlo
Penso sempre in maniera, in maniera
stupida che passi il cuore della gente
un po' come quando un figlio ti dice "Ti
odio" e tu capisci che non ti odierà mai
o quando tu dici "Mamma non voglio
più sentirti", ma in realtà la vuoi sentire due minuti dopo
Però va beh scusate sto diventando "C'è posta per te"
Ciao X, non so se hai visto ma nel mio ultimo video ho
ricevuto svariate critiche legate
alle reazioni che ho avuto nei confronti
del tuo messaggio
Vorrei innanzitutto chiederti scusa se
ti ho offesa con le mie parole
In secondo vorrei capire se vuoi che cosa sia
successo effettivamente
Attenendomi anche alle riflessioni che sono state
fatte sulla tua esperienza
vorrei capire quanto questo evento sia
effettivamente uno stupro e soprattutto
capire il motivo che ti ha spinto a parlare
di una cosa così importante e grave
con me piuttosto che con la polizia per
esempio. Te lo chiedo perché mi sto
flagellando oltremodo per il modo in cui
ho gestito questa confessione e vorrei
e vorrei cercare in te un po' di chiarezza se è possibile
Ti mando un bacio grandissimo, Gu
"Ciao Gu non ho fatto neanche in tempo a vedere il video in questione a dire il vero
Adesso guardo"...Le rispondo "In realtà il video non è presente
è stato tolto per evitare
di dare il messaggio sbagliato
sotto consiglio di alcuni utenti
Quello che vedi è un reedit del video
perché volevo evitare che la maggior
parte delle persone che non vedeva un
problema in un audio simile potesse
pensare che questa roba fosse normale
e tranquilla, ma di base i discorsi delle
persone mi hanno fatto pensare
più che altro a te e mi hanno spinto a voler
indagare sulla faccenda
Dall'audio non sono riuscito a capire
effettivamente quanto grave fosse stato il gesto
e quanto forte il tuo esserti ribellata
In che rapporti foste né quanto sia
durata la storia tra voi, avevo bisogno
di capire come mai non hai fatto nulla e hai lasciato correre
Insomma sento la responsabilità di ciò
che mi hai detto. Risponde lei
"Mi dispiace che il mio audio ti abbia
aggravato di una simile preoccupazione
te ne ho parlato perché io su questa storia sono totalmente tranquilla
perché nel momento in cui è
successa la cosa questa persona non mi
ha maltrattato o fatto del male, a parte
quello che ti ho detto, ma sono stata stupida io
a lasciarlo fare, perché
volevo vedere fino a che punto sarebbe arrivato
Io ne parlo tranquillamente
come se fosse un aneddoto divertente
e mi spiace che tu abbia potuto modificare il video. Avrei voluto potermi spiegare
anche con le persone che ti hanno
accusato di essere stato leggero sulla questione
Mi dispiace non aver visto il
video però cavolo"
"Tu sei sicura" le chiedo io "che non sia
stato uno stupro? Perché alcune persone
hanno percepito il fatto che tu ti
lamentavi e gli avessi detto di smettere
ma che lui continuasse a farlo contro la tua volontà
Io ammetto di averla percepita in
maniera più leggera ma ho avuto paurissima
di essere stato io leggero davanti a una
situazione grave invece"
Non ti preoccupare minimamente delle accuse alla mia persona adesso mi interessi solo tu"
Lei "No tu hai capito benissimo, lui era in dormiveglia e non si è neanche reso conto
di quello che ha fatto da quello
che mi ha detto poi dopo
Io mi sono lamentata ma avrei potuto interromperlo
quando volevo, solo che non l'ho fatto
perché volevo capire che persona fosse
Comunque ti ringrazio davvero molto per il tuo interesse
lo apprezzo e spero di averti
tranquillizzato". Le rispondo
"Le tue parole sono un vero sollievo, non c'ho ho dormito, calcola per paura che non stessi bene
Molto probabilmente farò un
video vabbè...non dirò il tuo nome ma
posso anche rassicurare le persone
perché un sacco di persone si sono
preoccupate comunque in tutto questo e avete fatto bene, avete fatto bene perché
appena m'avete svegliato svegliato pure io mi sono
preoccupato. Lei dice
"Si certo devi assolutamente farlo e mi spiace che
forse non sono state più leggera nel
raccontarlo di modo che tutti potessero
solo farsi una grassa risata
Le ho detto "Io in realtà avevo capito ma
magari non è stato chiaro per tutti
Ti mando un...un enorme bacio, grazie di cuore
non sai come sono più sollevato
Grazie ancora" Vabbé conferme...ci siamo detti un
pochino di cose affettuose
Adesso, questo è il dato di fatto ma alla luce di
questa cosa vorrei aggiungere una
piccola piccola piccola postilla, perché...perché la maggior parte delle persone
che seguono il mio canale sono donne...e
ed è a voi che voglio parlare perché io
credo che queste qui debbano essere
occasioni di crescita e non solamente
occasioni per sentirsi un pochino
con l'ego ferito e non essere stati capiti
perché molto probabilmente ho sbagliato
anch'io se uno non ha capito
effettivamente o magari  ho sbagliato
anch'io a montare questo, questo audio
che per me era così lampante mentre
invece sotto sotto lampante non lo era affatto
Sono contento che a questa
ragazza non sia successo niente ma allo
stesso tempo io invito a tutte le
persone che parlano di queste cose qui
molestie, maniaci, persone che allungano
le mani, di non parlarne con leggerezza
Non è una chiacchiera da fare con
l'amica perché il maniaco
dell'autobus a volte allunga la mano. Se voi
avete una persona che si azzarda
uomo donna che voi siate, uomo donna che
questo sia, se si azzarda a toccarvi
contro la vostra volontà voi alzate il
telefono e chiamate subito la polizia
Voi denunciate queste persone
Non sia mai argomento di risata con gli amici, non sia mai argomento di chiacchiera così
leggera per dare un aneddoto perché siamo troppo fighi
e nessuno riesce a starci...a starci lontano "Oh tu sfigata perché nessuno ti desidera"
No ragazzi questa è roba seria.
Ci si va in carcere ed è giusto anche che ci si vada
La violenza non è mai la
risposta. Io non credo nell'uguaglianza
non siamo nati tutti quanti uguali, io
sono uomo, tu sei donna, tu sei nero?
Io sono bianco
tu sei statuario...io lotto per esserlo ma
di base, il discorso è che io credo nella parità
Credo che ogni cosa che noi abbiamo non
ci renda superiore agli altri
siamo diversi sì, ma siamo pari e questo
è un pensiero che bisogna infilarsi nella testa
Adesso io vi ho detto come la penso
scusate prendo un respiro, perché vi giuro
molto probabilmente ora
chiuderò la cosa e scoppierò in un pianto
disperato perché me la sono veramente vissuta male
L'unica cosa che però dico è "Porca miseria
ragazzi!"
Se io sono un transfobico, maschilista, amico degli stupratori
veramente voi non avete visto chi c***o c'è là fuori. Posso essere un cattivo esempio
per un sacco di cose, ma
ragazzi ma quando si tratta di donne
veramente io le terre "così". Quando si
tratta di violenza ma io che sono stato
il primo a subirla, persone che ho
conosciuto sono stati i primi
che in parte, anche in aspetti piccoli, più grandi della vita, hanno subito queste cose
Ragazzi non si può parlare così
non si possono dire certe cose, perché se questo
qui è promuovere gli stupri io veramente
non so più con che bilancino pesiamo le
parole ed è veramente difficile parlare
Io chiudo questo video, non ho potere
sulle vostre vite ma voi ce l'avete
Fate la scelta giusta,
io non posso farlo per voi
Ciao